this is Mount leat toi luy luy rumbling
over Eastern Flores and sending up dense
plumes of hot ash from its crater since
late December with clouds as high as
1500 M the flow of lava has increased in
recent days the mountain has two peaks
but only one is
erupting there are still continuous
Tremors and low frequency earthquakes
this means the movement of magma to the
surface is very intense this can be seen
from the launching of lava in the
northeast of the
volcano most residents in nearby
Villages are staying in evacuation
centers this group has been sleeping in
a classroom since the beginning of the
year we have enough food here but my
children are starting to get health
problems they have fever and flu maybe
because they're sleeping on the floor
and because of the volcanic
ash most people in this area work in
farming or fishing the local government
says the eruption are affecting people's
livelihoods but safety has to come
first we keep publishing information so
people can understand that the impact of
the eruption is not just dust but also
pyroclastic
flow that pyroclastic flow travels fast
and is made up of gas Ash and fragments
of
rock authorities say people must stay
around 5 kilomet away from the center of
the eruption and they say there's also a
risk of cold lava flooding if heavy
rainfall occurs we're traveling through
the village of nellan authorities say
this is within the danger zone we're
joining them on patrol as they try to
find residents who haven't
evacuated but some residents have
refused to leave their homes and farm
animals in the beginning yes I was
afraid but now I'm used to the
rumbling authorities warn against such
complacency
saying the dangers are constantly
evolving as the eruptions
continue this Village is in the path of
a lava flow and volcanic ash it's very
important for people to leave this area
before this latest round of volcanic
activity the last recorded eruption at
Mount leat Toby luy luy was more than 20
years ago right now the volcano is on
Indonesia's highest alert of possible
eruption Jessica Washington out s East
Flores Indonesia